she was an Oscar winner for on the
waterfront and unforgettable in North by
Northwest as well as an Emmy winner and
for the kids among us was the voice of
Katara and the animated series The
Legend of Korra presenting the award to
Michelle Adkins is Eva Marie sent
thank you he swept me off my feet
did you see me almost and you know this
is a whole new thing or they've been
we've been doing it a few years the
actors terrific
I mean being an actress
I just love every one of you and you're
not getting paid right well oh oh you
are just say no they're not getting paid
when reading a script you hope to find
truth reality a well-defined characters
and a good story I found all the above
and talking about the sky by Michelle
hodkin sitting right there a lovely
lovely lady for me this is just an aside
has nothing to do with anything except
yesterday at the luncheon I met Michelle
for the first time as a fellow man
winner and I just happened to be wearing
a tan and Bey tan and black outfit guess
what she was wearing
Chenin town tan and black outfit and
tonight I'm wearing white and black and
guess what she's wearing so we were
meant to meet and be friends I was
captivated I was involved I was moved by
the story of Walter an aging man living
in a Fleetwood camper with his devoted
dog Henrietta I loved her that had a
happy ending by the way right did you
read the whole script yes of course you
did
I knew they would those kind of actors
right he was moving from trailer park to
trailer park we eventually learned that
he was a famous country singer but he
had a drinking problem and he had a
divorce and he had his daughter still
has that daughter but she has many
problems hopefully it's not in the
script
but hopefully she'll be helped and he
had a friend at the trailer park with
the son and all three became very close
we learned that Walter is very sick and
he's dying and he has to deal with that
reality and that is all very moving and
admirable
I asked Michelle at lunch yesterday
how could this young woman write about
such a character as Walter and she said
quote I met met an assortment oh she
said that she drove uber I always want
to say you burped my daughter says no
uber is that the right pronunciation
thank you
she said I was driving uber between jobs
and I met an assortment of characters
and gained an update close sometimes
personal glimpse into people's lives
their voices their appearances and
struggles came about for thoughts from
my writing hooray for uber and for
Michelle Adkins would you like to come
up now
and just when I think things can't get
any better I'm told Eva Marie Saint is
presenting me with this fellowship what
an absolute honor I'd like to thank Don
and Jeanne nickel for creating this
fellowship and Greg Beal and Joan why
for being the team that carries the
torch on such a wonderful tradition your
help and guidance throughout this
process has been invaluable to all the
committee members as a writer and a
person that reads other scripts and
gives notes frequently I know this takes
time your time and I thank you for
giving us all that a bit over a year ago
I drove for rideshare companies while
writing the script when I decided I
wanted to be on the creative side of
things rather than the number side it
took a bit of reorganization in my life
I thought often of Harper Lee who was
gifted a year of wages to write and
thank goodness she did because we were
given to kill a mockingbird and I
continued to think how nice that was for
her but that doesn't happen anymore now
does it but it just did and it happened
to me
I'd like to thank my many friends and
family members who are here and some who
are not I'd like to thank my mom my
constant cheerleader in life my writers
groups my teachers who took extra time
to help me and lend an ear to my husband
Joe in front of you all I would like to
apologize for our many disagreements on
grammar proper word placement and center
sentence structure all I can say is love
you baby doll lastly Brandon Mackenzie
my scriptwriting buddy who inspired me
in ways that can never be put into words
I am honored to have known you my friend
I'm overwhelmed with gratitude thank you